وتحول الى شرم الشيخ وهذه الجلسه الحواريه
حول اهميه العمل المناخي بمشاركه وزير
الطاقه السعودي وزير الخارجيه المصري سامح
شكري
وبالتالي من الجيد ان نقول ان هذه فكره
رائعه دعونا ننفذها وبعد سنوات
نجد ان هناك احداث كثيره حدثته ولم نستطيع
تطبيق الفكره اذا كيف ستكون بهذا
اولا الانجليزيه لغتي الثانيه
ولكن اقول انه حافظ على الزخم همم
مستقل ويستطيع المحافظه على نفسه همم في
ان المملكه العربيه السعوديه
لقائدها الشاب
ومساعده الشباب والشبات هم يريدون ان
يقوموا
بالافضل من اجل المستقبل لذا
فان لديهم فرصه
لدينا فرصه افضل مع الشباب
لتحقيق هذه طموحات
لانهم الشباب هم سيستفيدون من هذه
الطموحات وبالتالي فانه هناك فرصه افضل
لاظهار التزامهم واا خاصه انهم سيستفيدون
بشكل كبير من هذه المبادرات
نعم انه فعل الخير يبدا داخل الوطن لا
نستطيع ان نصل الى الجميع اذا لم نبدا
بانفسنا وبالتالي يجب ان نضرب المثل وان
يكون هناك التزام همم واستمراريه
حتى
ترى المنطقه ما نقوم به لذا فان لدينا اا
مبادره السعوديه الخضراء ولدينا مبادره
الشرق الاوسط
لانها على